My oncologist has me on lupron for metastatic prostate cancer and now wants me to take zytiga daily since I Tiga is I
Remember correctly. That's a droop. That's a daily drug for
testosterone energy deprivation therapy. I remember you had some reservations on zytiga
What's a zytiga
That I had reservations on I think when we were speaking it was the bone
drug
But in your opinion, what would be the long term use of this product on my body?
On the member site back to the member site again on the member site. There is a link to
a
Search bar of drug from drugs.com where you can search the
Side effects of all medication. I would do that
long-term effects of energy deprivation therapy is you know less and less testosterone and
the long-term effect is
the inability to get your testosterone back post treatment
And then if you're tolerating it well and you're not having any issues from it
Then I'd say continue if you're not tolerating it well, then you got to think about you know
Continue with energy deprivation therapy
Also, I have some concern in taking three five hundred milligram capsules of the b17 daily with meals
According to some literature no one should take more than ten apricot curtles per day, which average is about
200 milligrams
Well, that's interesting because all the literature for
Cancer is people are taking 20 to 50 apricot curtles per day
But the average apricot curtles 20 milligrams and
Be exposed to so much side I've 15 hundred milligrams of b17
Yeah, if you have issues with it
I mean some there's there are some people that are taking more than this and have no issues
There are some people that don't detoxify it well and they're getting some liver issues
At this dosage, so if you have concerns about it, you could just start with one of those a day. That's just fine
b17 amygdalen is a
Is it oxidative therapy for cancer? It can be very beneficial and
You certainly don't take
1,500 milligrams for months and months and months
Usually I have people on it for several months at a time and then we drop back to a different therapy
But if you feel have concerns about it by all means you got to
Make that old decision yourself. I'm just giving you an information to put what came up on your testing
So there's a lot of people after we do cheek swab testing
Funny is some people like hey have me do cheek swab tested. I do that
For them come up with a chronicle and they never end up buying the supplements
They never end up in supplements. They never follow through with anything I recommend it
You go no, I mean that's okay if you feel like God's leading you in a different direction. That's just fine
But you know, there's lots of people that do
Pay for a whole program and then don't seem to do anything much people that we've gotten right machines back
From family members of
Patient that started with us and we've never heard from them since they started and they pass away in the year too later
We get the right machine back and I have a way of looking at it and I realize they never even used the thing
It's just I don't know I don't know why people
Make the decisions. I want you to be praying about your decision
If you really feel like I think that's too much for me then by all means started a lower dosage
I want you to be responsible. I don't want you to
No, Dr. Carter said to this so I'm gonna do it. I don't want to have that type of relationship with you
That's the type of relationship that the medical professional wants to have with you. They want you to do exactly what they tell you. They are
somewhat next to God like and they want you to think that and they want
You to tell listen to everything they say. I'm just giving you my
You know
semi-educated opinion in everything. So I certainly don't know everything and
What I make recommendations about your cheek swap test is just as what's tested on you that day that we got that cheek swap
So that can change over time too and if you feel like God's leading you a different direction as far as dosage or something else
You feel like you should add on and I said this hundreds of times on this
Zoom call where people say I really feel like I really feel led to take this to what do you think?
Could I say and I won't do that by all means you need to be listening to God and having that relationship
With him that you can really feel like he's
leading you that's what I want from you most of all